un esfuerzo de rescate desesperado pero
con poco éxito hasta ahora casi 30 días
después de que una inundación atrapas ya
ocho obreros en una mina de zinc de
burkina faso no ha habido noticias de su
situación matthew battino un
sobreviviente el accidente estaba a 400
metros bajo tierra ese día pensando que
sería el último es un día que no
olvidaré hasta que muera escalamos ese
día matthew conducía una excavadora de
700 toneladas que fue arrastrada por la
corriente de agua ya que lobito no puede
salir tuve que ir por las salidas de
emergencia ahora pongo se acusa al grupo
canadiense que explota la mina de
retrasar las acciones de rescate
nos enfrentamos a una situación
totalmente imprevisible la cantidad de
agua adentro fue mucho mayor que la
bomba que tenía un chile le ponen
horario todos los días las familias de
los mineros desaparecidos se reúnen para
apoyar y rezar juntos una de las
presentes sylvie mamá vende ropa usada
pero cuenta con los ingresos de su
marido para mantener a sus cuatro hijos
o sea que funciona tenemos esperanza
sabemos que volverán realmente contamos
con dios para que vuelvan para que mi
marido vuelva madre sharon
mel en base embarazada de ocho meses
teme por el futuro de su hijo sin su
marido al lado llevo 26 días aquí
sentada todos los días desde la mañana
hasta la noche estamos desolados nadie
nos da respuestas concretas todos los
días esperamos buenas noticias y por eso
venimos aquí cada mañana es posible que
los hombres hayan llegado a una cámara
de rescate en la mina provista de comida
y agua pero el ministerio de trabajo de
burkina faso dice que hay que estudiar
primero las muestras de agua por razones
de seguridad antes de que los
rescatistas puedan sumergirse para
llegar al cuarto de salvamento